Ladies and gentlemen,
I'm a little off today because I keep getting the same comment over and over.
You guys think you're so smart telling me, Hey, Hey Steven, uh, your, your,
your door's backwards that it looks like you're standing outside of your office,
not inside of your office. Hey,
you guys haven't even seen the $10 million studio yet. I mean,
you guys have to listen up every single episode.
You can hear the faint sound here. I'll turn up, turn up the volume
here. That that's the sound of construction for the $10 million studio
going on. So yeah,
actually I've been just sitting outside my office this entire time.
People pass by all the time.
You wonder why you have so many jump cuts is because people start walking by.
So next time before you guys give me lip, let me do the work.
So all part of the plan,
we're going to show you the $10 million studio very shortly. In fact,
I'm going to give you a sneak preview at the end of this video,
but before any of that happens, sorry, we got to take these off.
I want to tell you guys a story about diabetes Island.
This is brought to you by our good friends at ClickBank. Let's watch.
Tell your children and husband, you love them and say goodbye. So the doctor,
you will be in a diabetic coma very soon. And I don't know what will happen.
Next terrified and barely conscious.
And my wife looked over at our two kids standing outside as he showed us the
test results. A normal blood sugar reading was one 21st was four 88.
Watch the machine, watch the show. I'm not ready to comment on it yet. Huh?
My bad-ass wife, the boss of our family,
a proud lady who would shut up anyone brave enough to give her lip trembling
cold and white as a sheet, 30 short minutes,
that was all he was giving my dear wife, Kathy,
before she would fall into unconsciousness.
As she lay in the cold steel hospital bed contemplating the most depressing
future she could imagine. I felt ashamed,
angry at God for inflicting this pain and misery on such a beautiful, caring,
loving woman.
Uh, what is, don't bring God into this. Your wife's in a diabetic coma. God,
didn't put the hohos in her hand. I mean, what do you want me to tell you?
So backup, sorry. He me off.
You see, despite what you've been told,
you're uncontrolled blood sugar and increasing belly fat has nothing to do with
how many sugars or carbohydrates you eat, how much exercise you do,
what medications you take or even genetics or the aging process.
This man's out here, overturning everything we know about diabetes.
Not due to food, not due to exercise, not even due to aging or genetics. What,
what could it be?
But it is instead all down to a little known,
but highly dangerous toxin found on every corner of earth. Well.
Cores, it's the little note sacred. How could I have not done?
It's never diet and exercise.
That's never the answer to any health problems on quick bag.
What was I thinking? I know it was the little known secret,
but what is that secret?
But there is an answer by using a simple 62nd habit twice a day known only to
the inhabitants of a small, barely populated AGN Island.
That's right ladies and gentlemen,
this is where we come to diabetes. Highland,
diabetes Island is a special place in the hearts of this man. But first of all,
who is this man?
My name is Eric Woodfield. I'm an iron worker, my wife,
Cathy and I live in Waco, New York. And I'm 53 years old.
Man, a blue collar man. He's the kind of man that wouldn't lie to you.
I've been a hardworking guy, all my life,
scaling skyscrapers and even done some ship fitting in my day.
Ship, fitting the ship, man.
Believe it or not.
I was even part of the cleanup crews sent to the ground zero after nine 11.
Oh, come on. Isn't it enough to lie to everyone?
Do you have to bring nine 11 into it? I probably could have guessed that.
Honestly, if you'd given me some options, he's a ship fit, man. Of course he,
he was on the cleanup crew of nine 11. In fact,
he was also part of the seal team six rate on a Sama bin Ladin.
That's the kind of man this man is.
Words are just so inadequate to try and share with you what I saw and felt
during those long, awful days,
you really understand what it means to come under attack and you know,
something that's happening to our bodies each and every day.
Did this man, just try to compare diabetes to a terrorist attack.
He's like, I know what it's like to be under attack from plane,
hijacking terrorists. You know what else is a plane hijacking, terrorists,
your blood cells,
driving it right into the twin towers of your aorta.
Fortunately for you,
a bizarre chain of events handed me the weapon I needed to defeat this invisible
diabetes causing toxin for good and save my wife's life.
Dude, if this were actually a true story,
which obviously I'm sure you guys know by now, it's not,
this should be the greatest movie ever told.
They'd make a Hollywood movie every year from this and then remake that movie
every single year. This would be the greatest story of all time,
if this were true, but you know what is true?
This guy hates the belly fat that this diabetes caused.
He found it disgusting. He keeps bringing it up in the story.
Piled on more and more weight.
She went from the energetic motivator to sluggish and overweight.
Then the space of just four years Kathy's weight had ballooned from a relatively
healthy 160 pounds to a massive 206.
Yeah, you can't talk about your wife that way.
Don't use the word massive as an adjective, by the way,
let's have a look at those little a before and after. Shall we.
Going from this to a slim and sexy 160?
Because all of a sudden when the magic diet is tried,
we get a before and after that seemed a little sus computer enhance
something about those faces seem suspicious. First of all,
nothing in her face changed.
Kathy has the remarkable ability to maintain the exact same face shape.
Even after going from a massive 216 pounds to a relatively healthy
160 pounds. So of course, you know me,
I had to look into it and what do you know?
Somebody else actually did the work for me, Contra health scam, shout out.
They discovered that this lady had been photo-shopped from another
weight loss journey. This is the real lady.
Her name is Kristen w and she won a little prize for losing the most weight.
And they took this poor lady and they photo-shopped her and Photoshop the new
face on her to give her the face of a nine 11 wife. Right?
But let's suspend our disbelief and continue with this journey of Eric
Whitfield. He's on a quest to discover the true cost, the hidden secret.
They don't want you to know about it.
I'd left online posts on forums and message boards.
He's all in like four Chan or eight Chan asking Q what the secret to diabetes is.
Fly from a man. We will call Kevin over a call.
He revealed to me the three closely guarded and biggest lies of the diabetic
industry. And this is the big diabetes lie. Number one,
lowering blood sugar will reverse diabetes. Next.
Kevin revealed big diabetes lie. Number two, this one shocked me.
Exercise helps reverse diabetes.
Like the, this guy is just lying to you. I mean,
I hope everyone knows that and giving out harmful information exercise actually
does help. Also. He can sell you a stupid product.
If medications,
exercise and carb restrictions had done nothing and would never do anything to
help Kathy's diabetes, then what could help badly? Kevin didn't have the.
And that's when he discovered diabetes Island.
And I was close to giving up.
And that's when I discovered something that chilled me to the bone.
Oh, sorry. We got to get into the super dramatic story. Before we get into that.
Hold on one.
I'm embarrassed to share this with you,
but I feel I have to using Kathy's laptop. One night,
I stumbled onto some of her Google searches. Best way to kill yourself.
I had one query.
Yay lady. Just cut back on the Twinkies a little bit.
You don't have to go that way.
We all eat a few too many quarter pounders from time to time, just chill out,
eat a salad. It's not going to kill you.
I had no idea. Kathy was feeling that low. I was desperate to help her,
but I didn't know how,
but that very night I received a phone call that would change everything.
That call came from my boss.
I had gotten an offer earlier that week for a big project over in Greece.
Pardon? After, after my long flight, I'm introduced to the team of guys.
I was supervising a group of 19 men from all over Greece among those
was Alexander Duka and seven other guys who came to work on the project from
their home on a tiny Greek Island called how come.
Welcome. We finally come full circle. Geez. These things.
As the weeks went on,
I came to realize these eight guys who were all in their mid fifties didn't have
diabetes or even a single symptom of it. They were slim healthy. And.
Yeah, maybe it's because they're outside working.
Back home. I didn't know of one person over 50 who didn't have diabetes,
let alone eight of them.
So that night I took Alex to one side and told him all about my wife's
conditions. Alex smiled,
patted me on the shoulder and told me to wait where I was a few minutes later,
he returned with a notepad and a pencil and began to scribble down what looked
like a recipe. What's this? I asked looking down the list,
the secret you've been searching for. He said with a Glint in his eye.
You see Eric, I'm a wizard.
Our health is all down to the food we eat. He continued mysterious.
Not that mysterious, but a second ago you were saying diet,
does it have anything to do with diabetes? Which is it, Eric, come on,
come on now.
Like eat these foods and your wife will recover with that. Alex stood up,
gave me a knowing smile and got back to work.
The only thing that I remember that Alex and his friends always made those
homemade dressings with their lunch and dinner. Sometimes even as a snack.
That's right, the secrets dressings.
They're going to teach you how to make for a small fee. But look,
if you think that's already gone to a conspiracy level, just wait.
Now,
stay with me here because this is where it gets very interesting particulate
matter. Also known as PM.
2.5 is a complex mixture of extremely small particles and liquid
droplets. They are admitted by fuel Bernie and various industrial sources,
but then get into the air and are inhaled. It's pretty scary, right? You see,
this is the real cause of your diabetes.
We know it's not because of your diet or how much exercise you do.
Your health has been deteriorating because of the invisible PM. 2.5,
which has been seeping into your bloodstream for days.
Get your tinfoil hats on boys. This Alice ain't seen nothing yet.
For this graph. We see diabetes started around the 1940s.
Now look at this graph of PM. 2.5 levels over time. Look familiar.
Notice the rapid incline at 1940 matches exactly when diabetes
spiraled out of control.
Oh, come on Eric. No, don't do that to us.
Don't give us the correlation equals causation argument, please.
You guys ever seen the cheese conspiracy before? Hey, check this out.
Cheese consumption is apparently correlated with people who died by becoming
tangled in their bedsheets. Coincidence.
Is it a coincidence that when people eat more cheese,
they get strangled in their bedsheets? I think not.
Yeah, it really, it was making sense now. And guess what?
While the level of pollution in Greece was one of the highest in the world,
far higher than the U S I found out that they actually had one of the lowest
levels of diabetes.
Hey boss,
we found out that our hypothesis is severely undercut by the fact that Greece
has way higher pollution levels than anywhere else. What should we say? Oh,
Oh, it just must be that the dressings that are so powerful.
It must be because of these traditional dressings and the ingredients that make
them up.
But the actual crazy thing is these guys, uh,
conveniently failed to mention that PM 2.5 emissions.
They cut the graph off at 2006 conveniently because they've actually been
falling in recent years.
So the little theory doesn't line up when diabetes goes up and PM two,
five goes down. They've literally cut off the graph, right?
When it disproves their theory completely because instead of actually telling
the truth,
they want to spin up a crazy conspiracy theory to endanger you so they can make
money brought to you by the guy who's stealing Valor from first responders at
nine 11. Anyways, I think that's a happy way to wrap it up. Uh,
needless to say,
don't ever follow these idiots advice or really anything you see on ClickBank.
That's all for now.
I think you guys have really earned this sneak peek that I'm about to show you
the $10 million studio. Please enjoy. Thanks for watching. And as always,
don't forget to smash like and subscribe. Thank you.